We have a responsibility as a
professional,
the timeline of the professional,
what's happening in the profession,
who has made a contribution and learn
from those things to free yourself to
become your own voice.
When I was building this house in North
Sea,
which were making the documentary of,
and I work with Peter Shelton,
my partner and my dear friend from
college read Morrison,
I realized there's the building went up.
I could kind of see the
intellectual collage of who I was as
pieces of the building stood at various
stages.
I could feel the ghost of Loucon.
When I looked at the poured concrete,
when I saw some of the glass details,
I kept thinking of the architects
collaborative in Boston.
When I looked at
some of the woodworking on the cladding,
I thought of Ed Barnes or Cert,
and then the way the stair was
conceived,
I thought of court was the a
and I started to realize that pieces of
who we are are often pieces of who we've
looked and studied,
but it's our responsibility to then
become ourselves.
So how do you take that where you can
almost dissect your own psyche and the
layers of building is such an
interesting tapestry of those pieces of
who you are and then hopefully when they
come together they become you,
but you owe to who you've become.
And then I realized when that building
was done,
because I love the archeology of great
people in my profession,
meaning whether it's their drawings,
their furniture,
their lighting
that kind of designed democracy emerged,
which is such an American idea
that we embrace many cultures and we
celebrate them and we celebrate ideas.
So the building was a kind of
international amalgam of people and
things that as Americans,
we're very open to and that I had
actually collected the archeology of
those people.
And as those things occupied the
building,
I realized that there archeology
informed the building that they inhabit.